(upbeat Latin music)
- What's up, guys?
So a few days ago, the beautiful people at Buzzfeed
decided to make a quiz about my favorite topic, which is me,
and so we decided to ask you guys questions to see
whether or not you guys know a lot
of random things about me.
I feel I think you guys are gonna do well,
'cause I'm pretty open about everything that I like
and everything that I don't like.
I think that there are gonna be some surprises,
'cause I feel like sometimes people think
that I'm a lot more foo-foo than I actually am.
(laugh)
I'm excited to see how you guys did, so let's go.
Let's get started.
^Alright, what kind of guy do you think Curly is most into?
Rich guys, oh man.
^Hairy guys, well-groomed guys, fashionable guys.
I definitely like rich guys,
so if you are rich and you're out there, I'm here for you.
Well-groomed guys.
I feel like I'm super hairy, so it's hard for me
to be well-groomed all the time,
so I don't wanna be the hairy one.
Fashionable guys!
There's only room for one in this relationship.
^So hairy guys!
Oh wow, you guys picked fashionable guys.
I like a guy who's just in a jersey
and sweatpants, gray sweatpants.
I like hairy guys 'cause there's something really sexy
about chest hair, arm hair, leg hair.
I will be in LA traffic and I will see five cars down,
somebody will put their hairy arm out and I'm like,
hairy arm alert!
I love it, it's so sexy.
You know, if you're born with back hair, I'm not mad at you.
I'm not gonna be like, ew, back hair,
but I can give or take.
If you have it, cool, if you don't, cool.
I do like booty hair, though.
^Would Curly rather wear a Selna outfit or a Beyonce outfit?
^Ooh, Selena outfit for sure.
I had one made custom-made for me.
(orchestral music)
- What are you wearing?
- What do you mean what am I wearing?
Selena, good job!
Good work, guys.
^Ooh, this one's a tricky one.
^Which Spice Girl is Curly's favorite.
^Ginger Spice, Sporty, Scary, Posh, or Baby?
^Wow, I think it's a complete tie between Ginger and Scary.
If I have to say which one I'm most like maybe in life,
I would have to say that I'm a Ginger Spice.
Actually, I'm definitely a Scary Spice.
(laughing)
Let's say Scary Spice.
Oh, wow!
You guys said Posh.
No.
Posh, you're amazing, and if you ever wanna be friends
or come over for dinner, I can make great barbecue chicken,
but I was always like, is Posh's microphone even on?
I don't understand why she...
When's her part coming?
(laughing)
When does she sing?
But I'm happy that Scary got second!
Yes, you guys know me so well.
Alright, I'm so happy.
Let's see what Ginger got.
Ginger was three!
See?
Y'all know it's between Scary or Ginger, for sure.
Sporty is last, 'cause you know damn well.
(laughing)
I'm not playing any damn sports any time soon.
^Does Curly tacos or pupusas?
^Pupusas all day.
55%, alright!
At my grandma's house, from my grandma's house,
always and forever.
^Would Curly rather marry a rich, beardless man,
^or a poor, hairy man?
^Here's my question, though.
When we made this question, a rich, beardless man,
does he have the ability to grow a beard, though?
'Cause can we pay for a beard, since he'll be rich?
My original answer was poor, hairy man,
but I'm gonna go ahead and change it
and say a rich, beardless man.
(ding)
(laughing)
You guys know me so well.
We'll just pay for the beard.
We'll just buy one.
(laugh)
Y'all know that I'm hella shallow when it comes to
how tall a guy's wallet it.
^Is Frankie and American bulldog or a pit bull?
This is up for debate, 'cause a lot of people,
when they see me walk him, they're like, nice,
American bulldog, but then other people will cross
the street 'cause they're like, I don't mess with pit bulls.
I think he's a mixture, but I'm gonna go ahead
and say that he's an American bulldog.
Wow, it's a tie.
(laugh)
^It's at 52% pit bull.
I always say he's a pit bull.
- You are always talking about pit bulls
and how he's a pit bull.
- I would love to believe that he's a pit bull,
but I think that people will debate me on this.
If you Google American bulldog and you look at Frankie,
and then you Google pit bull and you look at Frankie,
he looks closer to an American bulldog,
but we're gonna say he's mixed.
He's mixed race.
If I'm looking to write on a lease what kind of dog
I have in the apartment, I'm gonna write American bull dog
so I can get the apartment.
That's not good.
Don't bully my bully.
^Would Curly jump off of a cliff for $1,000,000
^or would he rather pay $1,000,000 to own a cliff.
I would rather pay $1,000,000 to own a cliff.
Ooh, yeah!
You guys got it right, good job!
I don't even jump into the deep end of a pool,
let alone a cliff.
So good job for knowing me that I would be
shallow enough to buy a cliff and name it after myself.
The only one that I am a little shocked about
is that you guys think I like Posh.
Really?
(meow)
I don't know what...
That's Posh's movement, by the way, but I don't know
where you would even get that I would like Posh.
I don't know.
(laughing)
But I'm happy you guys got Scary, 'cause yes.
She's the only Barbie that I own.
It's in my house somewhere.
Let me know how you guys did taking my quiz.
I'm super interested to see where you think I
answered something completely different.
(upbeat Latin music)
(whoosh)
(creak)